bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação da IBM
Quantum. Esta é a lição número 15 da série e é a terceira lição da quarta unidade, que trata de correção de erros quânticos.
Até agora vimos alguns exemplos de códigos corretores de erros quânticos, incluindo o código Shore de nove qubit
o código Steane de 7 qubit e o código de 5 qubit, e também discutimos o formalismo dos estabilizadores, que fornece
uma base matemática a partir da qual podemos descrever e analisar esses e muitos outros códigos corretores de erros quânticos.
Os códigos que acabei de mencionar são indubitavelmente interessantes e representam um ponto de partida natural para uma
exploração da correção de erros quânticos. O problema é que eles só conseguem tolerar uma taxa de erros muito baixa.
Corrigir um erro em um qubit de cinco, sete ou nove não é ruim, mas muito provavelmente, pelo menos até onde suspeitamos,
vamos precisar tolerar muito mais erros do que isso para tornar a computação quântica em larga escala uma
realidade. Nesta lição, daremos uma primeira olhada em algumas construções de códigos corretores de erros quânticos mais sofisticados, incluindo códigos que podem
tolerar uma taxa de erros muito mais alta do que os que vimos até agora e são vistos como candidatos promissores para correção de erros quânticos prática em
dispositivos físicos reais. Aqui está um breve panorama da lição: vamos começar com uma classe de
códigos corretores de erros quânticos conhecidos como códigos CSS, nomeados em homenagem aos pesquisadores que os descobriram: Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor e Andrew Steane. A construção do código CSS permite pegar certos pares de códigos clássicos
corretores de erros e combiná-los em um código corretor de erros quântico. Como parte dessa discussão, vamos
dar uma olhada bastante rápida nos códigos lineares clássicos e também falar sobre algumas das propriedades básicas dos códigos CSS.
A segunda parte da lição é sobre um código conhecido como código Tórico, que é um exemplo fundamental e realmente
belo de um código corretor de erros quântico que pode tolerar uma taxa de erros relativamente alta. Na verdade, o
código Tórico não é um único exemplo de código corretor de erros quântico, mas sim uma família infinita de códigos, um para
cada inteiro positivo a partir de dois. E na última parte da lição, discutiremos brevemente alguns outros
famílias de códigos quânticos, incluindo códigos de superfície, que estão intimamente relacionados ao código Tórico, bem como
códigos de cor. As pessoas estudam códigos corretores de erros clássicos desde a década de 1940
e é um assunto fascinante e rico. Os códigos lineares são talvez o tipo mais simples de erro clássico
corretor de erros, e vou explicar exatamente o que a palavra "linear" significa neste contexto em um momento, mas uma forma simples
de expressar o que eles são é que são códigos estabilizadores que por acaso são clássicos, e veremos em breve que
os códigos CSS são basicamente pares de códigos lineares clássicos que são combinados para criar um código corretor
de erros quântico. Portanto, para fins dessa discussão, precisamos entender alguns conceitos básicos sobre
códigos lineares clássicos. Primeiro, vamos tomar Sigma como o alfabeto binário para toda esta
discussão, e agora quando nos referimos a um código linear clássico queremos dizer um conjunto C de strings binárias de comprimento n para algum
inteiro positivo n satisfazendo apenas uma propriedade básica, que é: se u e v são strings binárias em C, então a string
u XOR v também está em C. Aqui, por sinal, u XOR v significa o ou-exclusivo bit a bit de u e v, assim como
vimos várias vezes nas lições cinco e seis na parte de algoritmos quânticos da série, e é isso que significa um
código clássico ser linear. Em essência, estamos pensando em strings binárias de comprimento n como vetores de dimensão n
onde as entradas são todas zero ou um, mas em vez da adição vetorial ordinária sobre os números reais ou complexos
estamos usando adição módulo 2, que é simplesmente o XOR. Então, se tivermos
duas palavras-código u e v, ou seja, u e v são strings binárias em C, então u mais v módulo 2, ou em outras palavras u XOR
v também deve ser uma palavra-código em C. E por sinal, essa implicação deve ser verdadeira mesmo que u seja igual a v — nada descarta
essa possibilidade, e isso implica que todo código linear clássico deve conter a string toda-zero, porque o
XOR bit a bit de qualquer string consigo mesma é a string toda-zero. Por exemplo, o
código de repetição de três bits é um código linear clássico. Em particular, há duas escolhas possíveis para u e duas possíveis
escolhas para v, e é bem trivial percorrer os pares possíveis para ver que sempre obtemos uma palavra-código quando tomamos o
XOR bit a bit. Aqui está outro exemplo, chamado código de Hamming 743. Este é um dos primeiros
códigos corretores de erros clássicos que já foram descobertos, e consiste em 16 strings binárias de comprimento sete. Há uma lógica muito simples
por trás da seleção dessas strings, mas não vou explicar isso neste vídeo, e também devo mencionar que às vezes você verá essas strings invertidas, mas
por ora o ponto principal é que se pegarmos quaisquer duas dessas strings e fizermos XOR entre elas, obteremos outra string no
código, então é um código linear. E a notação 743 entre colchetes simples significa algo análogo à notação de colchetes duplos
que mencionei na lição anterior para códigos estabilizadores, mas aqui é para códigos lineares clássicos.
Em particular, as palavras-código têm sete bits, existem 16 palavras-código, então podemos codificar quatro bits usando o código, e
acontece de ser um código de distância três, o que significa que você precisa inverter pelo menos três bits de qualquer palavra-código para obter
uma palavra-código diferente, e isso implica que ele pode corrigir até um erro de inversão de bit. Esses são exemplos simples de
códigos, mas mesmo o exemplo do código de Hamming 743 parece meio misterioso quando simplesmente listamos todas as palavras-código, então precisamos de melhores formas de
descrever códigos lineares clássicos, e há duas formas naturais de fazer isso. Uma forma é descrever códigos lineares
clássicos fornecendo um conjunto mínimo de palavras-código que geram o código, o que significa que tomando todos os subconjuntos possíveis
dessas palavras-código e fazendo XOR entre eles obtemos o código inteiro, e isso é expresso em termos matemáticos
aqui na tela. Outra forma de pensar nisso é que estamos vendo este código como um subespaço de um espaço vetorial, e este conjunto
de geradores é uma base para esse subespaço — lembrando que este é um espaço vetorial onde a aritmética é feita módulo 2. Se temos M geradores, vamos
obter um código com dois elevado a M elementos; cada gerador dobra o número de elementos no código, e
isso é consistente com o fato de que códigos lineares clássicos sobre o alfabeto binário sempre incluem um número de strings que é uma potência de
dois. A segunda forma natural de descrever um código linear clássico é por verificações de paridade. Especificamente, é uma lista mínima
de strings binárias com o mesmo comprimento das strings no código, de forma que as strings no código são precisamente aquelas cujo
produto interno binário com cada uma dessas strings de verificação de paridade é zero, onde o produto interno binário é simplesmente o
produto interno ordinário módulo 2, e novamente isso é algo que encontramos na lição cinco no contexto de algoritmos de consulta.
E a razão pela qual são chamadas de strings de verificação de paridade é que uma dada string u tem produto binário igual a
zero com v se e somente se os bits de u correspondentes aos uns em v têm paridade
par. Quando descrevemos um código linear clássico desta forma, por uma lista mínima de strings de verificação de paridade, cada string de
verificação de paridade divide o número de strings no código por dois. Portanto, para um único código descrito de duas formas diferentes, sempre teremos m + r igual a
n. Uma coisa importante a notar aqui é que o produto interno binário não é um produto interno no sentido formal, e em
particular, quando duas strings têm produto interno binário igual a zero, isso não significa que são ortogonais da forma usual como pensamos sobre
ortogonalidade. Por exemplo, o produto interno binário da string 1 1 consigo mesma é zero, então é possível que
uma dessas strings de verificação de paridade esteja ela mesma no código. Então é só algo a se ter em
mente. Por exemplo, como já sabemos, o código de repetição de 3 bits é um código linear, então pode ser descrito de ambas as formas.
Em particular, há apenas uma escolha para um gerador que funciona, e essa é 111, e podemos alternativamente descrever
o código com essas duas strings de verificação de paridade, que devem parecer familiares das nossas discussões anteriores sobre este
código. E para o código de Hamming 743, podemos usar esses geradores e essas verificações de
paridade, e aqui, aliás, todas as nossas strings de verificação de paridade acabam por estar elas mesmas no código.
Um comentário final sobre códigos lineares clássicos, só para conectá-los ao formalismo dos estabilizadores: essas strings de verificação de paridade
são equivalentes a geradores estabilizadores onde temos apenas matrizes de Pauli Z e identidade. Por exemplo, as strings de verificação de paridade
110 e 011 para o código de repetição de 3 bits correspondem precisamente aos geradores estabilizadores ZZ identidade
e identidade ZZ, e isso é consistente com nossa discussão de observáveis desse tipo da lição anterior.
A seguir, vamos discutir os códigos CSS, que são códigos estabilizadores que podem ser obtidos combinando certos
pares de códigos lineares clássicos com o mesmo número de bits em suas codificações. Isso não funciona para quaisquer dois
códigos lineares clássicos — os dois códigos precisam ter uma certa relação, como veremos em breve, mas ainda assim esta
construção abre muitas possibilidades para códigos corretores de erros quânticos baseados, em parte, em coisas que aprendemos ao longo de mais de 75 anos de
teoria de codificação clássica. Já mencionei que no formalismo dos estabilizadores, geradores estabilizadores
contendo apenas matrizes de Pauli Z e identidade são equivalentes a verificações de paridade. Por exemplo, no código de repetição de três bits
podemos usar as strings de verificação de paridade 1 1 0 e 011, que forçam os dois bits mais à esquerda a serem
iguais e os dois bits mais à direita a serem iguais para toda string no código, e essas duas strings de verificação de paridade correspondem precisamente aos geradores estabilizadores
ZZ identidade e identidade ZZ. Para o código de Hamming 743 podemos usar
essas strings de verificação de paridade, e elas correspondem a esses geradores estabilizadores, onde simplesmente substituímos cada um por Z e cada zero pela identidade.
Você talvez reconheça esses geradores estabilizadores, porque estes são três dos seis geradores estabilizadores para o código Steane de 7 qubit — isso
certamente não é uma coincidência, e veremos exatamente o que está acontecendo aqui em breve. Vamos dar o nome de geradores Z
estabilizadores a geradores estabilizadores como este, o que significa que eles só têm fatores tensoriais de Pauli Z e identidade,
então X e Y nunca ocorrem em um gerador Z estabilizador. Também podemos considerar
geradores estabilizadores onde apenas matrizes de Pauli X e identidade aparecem, e podemos pensar em geradores estabilizadores como estes como sendo completamente análogos
a geradores Z estabilizadores, exceto que eles basicamente descrevem verificações de paridade na base mais/menos em vez da
base padrão. Por exemplo, voltando ao código de Hamming 743, podemos pensar sobre os
três geradores estabilizadores restantes do código Steane de 7 qubit, que seguem exatamente o mesmo padrão que para os geradores Z estabilizadores para este
código, mas desta vez substituímos X por um em vez de Z, e o que obtemos apenas desses três geradores estabilizadores
é um código que inclui os 16 estados mostrados aqui, que obtemos aplicando gates Hadamard aos estados da base
padrão correspondentes às strings no código de Hamming 743, e claro nosso espaço de código também inclui
combinações lineares desses estados. Naturalmente, geradores estabilizadores dessa forma são chamados de geradores X estabilizadores
— então nenhum Y ou Z é permitido desta vez. E agora podemos definir os códigos CSS em
termos simples: códigos CSS são códigos estabilizadores que podem ser expressos usando apenas geradores Z
estabilizadores e geradores X estabilizadores — então nenhum Y é permitido e nenhum X e Z aparecem no mesmo gerador estabilizador.
E para garantir que isso esteja claro, devemos lembrar que há liberdade em como escolhemos os geradores estabilizadores para códigos
estabilizadores, e o que esta definição está dizendo é que um código CSS é aquele para o qual é possível escolher apenas geradores
estabilizadores Z e X, mas em geral você poderia escolher geradores estabilizadores diferentes que podem não ser geradores Z ou X estabilizadores se quisesse.
Aqui está praticamente o exemplo não-trivial mais simples de um código CSS que podemos ter, onde há tanto um gerador Z estabilizador
quanto um gerador X estabilizador, e verificar isso requer não mais do que uma olhada rápida, dado que já sabemos da
lição anterior que este é um código estabilizador válido. O espaço de código é unidimensional — é o espaço gerado por um
ebit de mais, e podemos observar que nossos dois geradores estabilizadores agem trivialmente sobre esse vetor considerando
as duas expressões de um ebit mostradas na tela, juntamente com a interpretação dos geradores estabilizadores como verificações de paridade nas bases 0/1
e mais/menos. O código Steane de 7 qubit é outro exemplo de código CSS porque para esta
escolha de geradores temos apenas geradores Z estabilizadores e X estabilizadores, e novamente já sabemos que este é um
código estabilizador válido. E o código Shore de N=9 qubit é outro exemplo — desta vez temos seis geradores Z
estabilizadores e apenas dois geradores X estabilizadores, e tudo bem — não precisa haver equilíbrio ou
simetria entre os dois tipos. É, no entanto, crítico que tenhamos de fato um código estabilizador válido, e isso significa
que cada um dos geradores Z estabilizadores deve comutar com cada um dos geradores X estabilizadores — então você não pode
simplesmente escolher os dois tipos de geradores de forma independente, e direi um pouco mais sobre isso mais adiante na lição. A seguir, vamos discutir a detecção
e correção de erros para códigos CSS, e o que descobriremos é que a propriedade que observamos para o código Shore de 9 qubit
— que podemos detectar e corrigir erros X e erros Z de forma independente — vale em geral para os códigos CSS.
Para explicar isso melhor, vamos considerar um código CSS como o código Steane de 7 qubit, mas poderia ser um código CSS diferente se
você preferir. A ideia básica é que os geradores Z estabilizadores detectam erros X
mas são completamente alheios a erros Z, porque geradores Z estabilizadores sempre comutam com erros Z.
Além disso, os geradores Z estabilizadores também comutam com quaisquer gates Z que possamos escolher aplicar como
correções para erros Z. De forma análoga, os geradores X estabilizadores detectam erros Z, mas são completamente
alheios a erros X e correções. Então podemos, em essência, pensar nos geradores Z estabilizadores como representando um
código linear clássico que protege contra inversões de bits, ou seja, erros X, enquanto os geradores X estabilizadores
representam um código linear clássico na base mais/menos que protege de forma completamente independente contra inversões
entre estados mais e menos, ou seja, erros de inversão de fase, ou erros Z. Então agora fica bastante evidente o que está acontecendo
com o código Steane: é simplesmente um código de Hamming 743 para erros de inversão de bit e um código de Hamming 743 para erros de inversão de
fase. Mais uma vez, o fato de que os geradores Z estabilizadores e os geradores X estabilizadores comutam é necessário —
não seria um código estabilizador válido se não comutassem, e você poderia dizer que é uma boa sorte que o código de Hamming 743
funcione assim, mas há muitas outras escolhas que podem ser feitas para pares de códigos lineares clássicos que nos darão um código estabilizador válido
quando combinados dessa forma. Agora, voltando aos códigos CSS em geral, suponha que os geradores Z estabilizadores
permitam a correção de até, digamos, j erros X, e os geradores X estabilizadores permitam a correção de
até k erros Z. Então, no caso do código Steane, j e k são ambos um porque
o código de Hamming 743 pode corrigir uma inversão de bit, mas em geral esses números j e k podem ser diferentes.
Segue-se então pela discretização de erros que o código CSS pode corrigir qualquer erro em um número de qubit até
o mínimo de j e k. Isso porque quando medimos a síndrome, um erro arbitrário em algum
número de qubit colapsa de forma probabilística em alguma combinação de erros X, erros Z, ou ambos, e então
os erros X e Z podem ser detectados e corrigidos de forma independente. Então, desde que tenhamos dois
códigos lineares clássicos que se entendam no sentido de que nos dão geradores X e Z estabilizadores que comutam, o
código CSS que obtemos ao combiná-los basicamente herda as propriedades de correção de erros dos dois códigos no sentido que acabei de
descrever. Note que há um preço a pagar, no entanto, que é que não podemos codificar tantos qubit quanto poderíamos codificar bits
com os dois códigos clássicos, porque o número total de geradores estabilizadores para o código CSS é a soma do
número de verificações de paridade dos dois códigos clássicos, e cada gerador estabilizador corta a dimensão do espaço de código pela
metade. Por exemplo, o código de Hamming 743 permite a codificação de quatro bits clássicos porque temos apenas
três verificações de paridade para este código, enquanto o código Steane de 7 qubit codifica apenas um qubit porque tem seis
geradores estabilizadores. A última coisa que vou explicar sobre códigos CSS em geral nesta lição diz respeito aos espaços de código dos códigos CSS
e como eles se parecem, e isso também nos dará a chance de examinar um pouco mais detalhadamente a relação que precisa valer entre
dois códigos lineares clássicos para que sejam compatíveis no sentido de que podemos combiná-los para formar um código CSS.
Considere um código CSS arbitrário em N qubit, e seja Z1 até Zs as strings de paridade de N bits
que correspondem aos geradores Z estabilizadores. Isso significa que o código linear
clássico descrito pelos geradores Z estabilizadores, que chamaremos de CZ só para nos ajudar a lembrar que este
é o código correspondente aos geradores Z estabilizadores, tem a forma mostrada aqui na tela. Em palavras, o código contém toda
string u cujo produto binário com cada uma das strings de verificação de paridade é zero. Bem, se quiséssemos, poderíamos também
considerar um código diferente derivado dessas mesmas strings, que chamaremos de DZ, e a ideia aqui é que pensamos sobre
essas strings Z1 até Zs não como strings de verificação de paridade, mas sim como geradores.
Neste ponto, não está claro por que gostaríamos de pensar sobre este código, mas podemos, e isso acabará sendo relevante para esta
discussão. Este código é chamado de código dual de CZ, e é comumente denotado CZ perpendicular, ou seja, CZ com o símbolo de perpendicular
como sobrescrito, mas vamos chamá-lo de DZ, e isso será fácil de lembrar porque D é a abreviação de
dual. Também podemos fazer algo similar com os geradores X estabilizadores, então desta vez CX é o código linear clássico
cujas strings de verificação de paridade correspondem aos geradores X estabilizadores, e DX é o código dual deste código. Como observação à parte,
podemos agora descrever as condições que devem valer para que CZ e CX sejam compatíveis no sentido de que podemos
combiná-los como um código CSS, em termos desses próprios códigos. Especificamente, deve ser que
DZ está contido em CX, ou equivalentemente que DX está contido em CZ. E agora é
possível descrever o espaço de código do código CSS derivado desses dois códigos, e uma forma de descrevê-lo é que
é o espaço gerado por todos os vetores que têm a forma mostrada na tela. Em palavras, eles parecem superposições uniformes
sobre as strings no código dual DX do código correspondente aos geradores X estabilizadores, deslocadas
ou com XOR feito por strings no código CZ correspondente aos geradores Z estabilizadores, e veremos como isso se parece
no caso específico do código Steane em um momento. Isso faz sentido porque os estados no espaço de código devem ser
vetores próprios de autovalor +1 de todos os geradores estabilizadores, e em particular multiplicar por qualquer um dos geradores X
estabilizadores é equivalente a fazer XOR com a string X correspondente, então é por isso que essas superposições uniformes
sobre DX deslocadas por strings diferentes aparecem assim. Escolhas diferentes para o deslocamento
representado pela string Y nesta expressão podem nos dar o mesmo vetor, aliás, então esses estados não são todos distintos, mas coletivamente eles geram o
espaço de código inteiro. Há uma simetria aqui entre os geradores X e Z estabilizadores e
os códigos aos quais eles correspondem, e então podemos usar essa simetria para descrever vetores no espaço de código de forma análoga, trocando X e Z, mas
também precisamos trocar as bases padrão pelas bases mais/menos, e é por isso que as operações Hadamard aparecem nesta
expressão. Agora, para o exemplo que foi prometido, que é o código Steane, acabamos com essas duas codificações possíveis como
codificações dos estados da base padrão zero e um. Em particular, podemos codificar o estado zero como uma superposição
uniforme sobre as oito strings no código dual do código de Hamming 743, que acaba sendo metade das strings no código de Hamming 743, e podemos
codificar o estado um de forma similar, exceto que todas as strings têm XOR com a string toda-um neste caso.
porque essa string está no código de Hamming 743, mas não no seu dual. Um comentário final aqui é que muitas vezes
não nos importamos tanto com a aparência dos vetores em nossos espaços de código, porque geralmente não precisamos saber isso para usar os
códigos. Então se essa explicação não ficou clara, realmente não é algo para se preocupar muito, mas certamente é
natural perguntar como são os vetores nos espaços de código dos códigos CSS, e essa descrição fornece uma resposta a essa
pergunta. A seguir, vamos discutir um código CSS específico conhecido como código Tórico, que é um exemplo de algo conhecido como
código corretor de erros quântico topológico. Este código foi descoberto por Alexei Kitaev em
1997. Na verdade, o código Tórico não é um único código, mas sim uma família de códigos, um para cada inteiro positivo de
pelo menos dois. Esses códigos possuem algumas propriedades fundamentais. A primeira propriedade fundamental é
que todos os geradores estabilizadores têm baixo peso como operações de Pauli. Em particular, todos terão
peso quatro, e isso é bom porque significa que cada medida de gerador estabilizador não precisa
envolver muitos qubit. Às vezes as pessoas falam de códigos LDPC quânticos, ou códigos quânticos de verificação de paridade de baixa densidade
e é isso que se quer dizer com esse termo, onde neste caso baixo significa quatro. Então o código Tórico é um exemplo de
código LDPC quântico. O código Tórico também tem o que é chamado de localidade geométrica, o que significa que não
só os geradores estabilizadores têm baixo peso, mas também é possível arranjar os qubit espacialmente de forma que
cada medida de gerador estabilizador envolva apenas qubit que estejam próximos uns dos outros, o que torna essas medidas mais fáceis de implementar em
princípio. E finalmente, esses códigos têm grande distância, então podem tolerar uma taxa relativamente alta de
erros. Veja como esses códigos funcionam: primeiro, seja L um inteiro positivo
de pelo menos dois, e considere uma rede L por L com as chamadas fronteiras
periódicas. Por exemplo, aqui está uma rede L por L para L igual a 8, e observe que as linhas
à direita e na parte inferior são linhas pontilhadas, e a ideia aqui é que queremos pensar na linha pontilhada à direita como sendo a mesma linha que
a linha à esquerda, e da mesma forma a linha pontilhada na parte inferior é a mesma linha que a da
parte superior. Então, se realmente quiséssemos realizar esse tipo de configuração fisicamente, precisaríamos de três
dimensões. Em particular, poderíamos formar um cilindro primeiro combinando os lados esquerdo e direito e depois dobrar o
cilindro de forma que os círculos nas extremidades — que antes eram as bordas superior e inferior da rede — se encontrem, ou você
poderia combinar a parte superior e inferior primeiro e depois os lados; funciona das duas formas e não importa como você faz isso para os fins desta
discussão. O que obtemos é um Toro ou, em outras palavras, uma rosca, embora pensar nele como a câmara interna de um pneu seja
talvez uma imagem melhor a ter em mente, porque isso não é um sólido — a rede na verdade se tornou apenas a superfície de um
Toro, e é daí que vem o nome código Tórico. A forma como você pode se mover em um
Toro como esse — assumindo que você consegue se mover entre pontos adjacentes na rede — provavelmente será familiar para quem já jogou videogames antigos,
onde se você sair pela borda superior da tela você aparece na parte inferior, e da mesma forma para as bordas esquerda e direita da
tela. E é basicamente assim que vou descrever esta rede, como alternativa a falar especificamente sobre um
Toro em um espaço tridimensional. A seguir, imaginamos que qubit são
colocados nas arestas da rede, como ilustrado aqui na tela, onde qubit são indicados por círculos azuis sólidos.
Observe que os qubit colocados nas linhas pontilhadas não são sólidos, e isso porque já representamos esses qubit
pelos que estão ao longo da parte superior ou do lado esquerdo — lembrando que as linhas na parte superior e à esquerda são exatamente as mesmas linhas que as
indicadas pelas linhas pontilhadas na parte inferior e à direita. Então, se contarmos todos esses qubit, obtemos 2 * L² qubit, e uma
forma de ver isso é observar que obtemos L² qubit nas arestas horizontais e L² qubit nas arestas verticais.
Então esse é o layout dos nossos qubit, e para descrever o código Tórico em si, só precisamos descrever os geradores
estabilizadores, e há dois tipos deles. Primeiro, temos geradores Z estabilizadores
e estes correspondem a tiles ou placas na figura. E segundo, temos geradores X estabilizadores
e estes correspondem a vértices na figura. Então, por exemplo, aqui está um
gerador estabilizador, o que significa que estamos fazendo o produto tensorial de uma operação de Pauli Z para cada um dos qubit que tocam este tile, juntamente com matrizes identidade
em todos os outros qubit, e isso nos dá uma operação de Pauli de peso quatro. E aqui está um exemplo de um gerador X
estabilizador, onde temos matrizes de Pauli X atuando nos quatro qubit incidentes a este vértice, juntamente com
matrizes identidade em todos os outros qubit. Então mais uma vez é uma operação de Pauli de peso quatro. É importante que para ambos
esses tipos de geradores estabilizadores incluamos os que envolvem as fronteiras periódicas, e aqui está um exemplo de um gerador X estabilizador
que faz isso. Agora, para obter um código estabilizador válido, precisamos que os geradores
estabilizadores comutem. Os geradores Z estabilizadores todos comutam entre si porque Z comuta consigo mesmo e a identidade
comuta com tudo, e da mesma forma para os geradores X estabilizadores. Também é claro que um gerador Z estabilizador e um
gerador X estabilizador comutam quando atuam de forma não-trivial em conjuntos disjuntos de qubit, como nos dois geradores mostrados
aqui. A possibilidade restante é que um gerador Z estabilizador e um gerador X estabilizador se sobreponham, e
sempre que isso acontece, é sempre em dois qubit que eles se sobrepõem, então os geradores estabilizadores comutam porque ZZ
e XX comutam. Agora, este não é um conjunto mínimo de geradores estabilizadores. Em particular, se multiplicarmos
todos os geradores Z estabilizadores juntos obtemos a identidade, porque cada qubit é multiplicado por Z duas vezes —
uma vez para cada um dos tiles que toca o qubit. Isso significa que multiplicar todos os geradores Z estabilizadores juntos
exceto um nos dá esse último, então eles não são independentes. Mas se removermos qualquer um deles, obteremos
um conjunto independente, e o mesmo é verdade para os geradores X estabilizadores. Então podemos remover um de cada —
e não importa quais removemos — e isso deixa L² menos um geradores estabilizadores de cada tipo. Para ser
claro sobre isso — e isso é algo que aludí na lição anterior — na verdade nos importamos com todos esses geradores estabilizadores, e em um sentido estritamente
operacional não vamos realmente escolher um de cada tipo para ignorar, mas para fins de análise do código podemos
imaginar que um gerador estabilizador de cada tipo foi removido para que obtenhamos um conjunto gerador mínimo, tendo em
mente que poderíamos sempre inferir os resultados desses geradores removidos — pensando neles como observáveis — dos resultados de todos os outros geradores
estabilizadores observáveis do mesmo tipo. Então o número de qubit que este código codifica é igual ao número total de
qubit, que é 2 * L², menos o número total de geradores estabilizadores em um conjunto gerador mínimo, que é 2 * L² -
1, e isso significa que podemos codificar 2 qubit. Não argumentei, aliás, que o espaço de código é não-trivial, mas de fato
é não-trivial, e deixo para você se convencer de que não há como multiplicar geradores estabilizadores de uma forma que nos dê
menos 1 vezes a identidade. Então é esse o código Tórico em si, e neste ponto pode não estar
nada claro por que este código deveria ser bom para correção de erros quânticos. Resta-nos analisá-lo, e o que descobriremos é que é, de fato,
um código corretor de erros quântico bastante incrível. Para entender como o código Tórico funciona como um código corretor de erros quântico,
vamos começar considerando diferentes erros e as síndromes que eles geram. A primeira coisa a notar é que
o código Tórico é um código CSS porque todos os nossos geradores estabilizadores são geradores Z estabilizadores ou X estabilizadores,
e isso significa que erros X e erros Z podem ser detectados e possivelmente corrigidos
separadamente. E de fato há uma simetria simples entre os geradores Z e X estabilizadores que nos permite analisar erros X
e erros Z de essencialmente a mesma forma. Então vou me concentrar em erros X, que são possivelmente detectados pelos geradores Z
estabilizadores, e você pode traduzir tudo para erros Z, que são possivelmente detectados pelos geradores X estabilizadores, usando exatamente as
mesmas ideias. Aqui está uma figura ilustrando nossos dois qubit² nas arestas de uma rede L por L
com fronteiras periódicas, e podemos imaginar que isso está disposto na superfície de um
Toro. Por ora, todos os qubit são azuis, indicando que são qubit que não foram afetados por
erros. Então você deve imaginar que neste ponto o estado desses qubit está no espaço de código para este
código. Como mencionei, nosso foco serão os erros X, e em um momento usaremos círculos magenta para indicar qubit que
foram afetados por erros X. Os erros X são detectados pelos geradores Z estabilizadores, que correspondem
aos tiles na figura. Então o que podemos fazer é usar tiles brancos para indicar resultados de medida mais um, ou seja, entradas
na síndrome correspondentes a esse gerador, enquanto tiles cinzas indicarão resultados de medida menos um.
Você pode pensar num resultado mais um, ou seja, um tile branco, como indicando que o gerador estabilizador correspondente
está feliz — tudo parece estar bem para este gerador. Bem, um resultado menos um ou tile cinza
indica que o gerador estabilizador correspondente está infeliz, porque obviamente um erro deve ter ocorrido para causar este
resultado. Então, por ora, todos os nossos geradores estabilizadores estão felizes porque nenhum erro ocorreu. Agora, se pensarmos
sobre um gerador Z estabilizador, tudo o que ele faz é medir a paridade dos 4 qubit que tocam o tile com
relação à base padrão. Então um resultado mais um não indica que nenhum erro X ocorreu nesses quatro
qubit, mas sim que um número par de erros X ocorreu, enquanto um resultado menos um indica
que um número ímpar de erros X ocorreu. Então agora vamos introduzir um erro X e ver o que
acontece. Os dois geradores Z estabilizadores correspondentes aos tiles que tocam este qubit agora estão infelizes porque este
erro X anti-comuta com ambos esses geradores, ou equivalentemente em termos da base padrão estamos agora em
um estado onde ambos esses conjuntos de quatro qubit correspondentes aos dois tiles têm paridade ímpar. Então é o efeito de um único
erro X. Então, se medíssemos esta síndrome e soubéssemos ou assumíssemos que apenas um erro X ocorreu, seríamos
capazes de inferir facilmente qual qubit inverteu e poderíamos simplesmente invertê-lo de volta com um gate X. Agora vamos ver o que acontece
quando introduzimos erros X adicionais e em particular vamos ver o que acontece quando um segundo erro X ocorre em outro
qubit tocando um dos tiles cinzas — digamos o tile cinza no topo, como
este. Esse tile agora está feliz porque dois erros X ocorreram nos qubit tocando este tile, e dois é par, então
esses dois erros X juntos comutam com o gerador estabilizador para este tile. Outra forma de dizer isso é que
este segundo erro X deslocou todos os estados da base padrão desses quatro qubit de paridade ímpar de volta para paridade par.
O tile à esquerda deste novo erro X, por outro lado, agora está infeliz.
Podemos continuar esse processo de adicionar novos erros X e, desde que formemos uma cadeia de erros X adjacentes — onde adjacente significa que os qubit tocam o
mesmo tile — vamos efetivamente empurrar este resultado de medida menos 1 ao redor, e o que descobrimos é que sempre temos
resultados de medida de síndrome menos um nas extremidades de cadeias de erros adjacentes. Então sempre podemos detectar cadeias de
erros X adjacentes, desde que tenham extremidades. Pode haver, aliás, múltiplas cadeias, mas voltaremos
a essa possibilidade mais tarde. É possível, no entanto, ter uma cadeia de erros X adjacentes que
não tem extremidades — ou seja, nossa cadeia de erros poderia formar um loop fechado. Então vamos adicionar mais erros de forma
que formem um loop fechado como este, por exemplo. Agora temos um número par de erros X
em cada tile, então todo gerador estabilizador agora está feliz, e o que descobrimos é que loops
fechados de erros X adjacentes não são detectados por este código, porque obtemos a síndrome toda-mais-1 em tal
caso. Então isso pode parecer um pouco decepcionante — na verdade precisamos apenas de quatro erros X adjacentes para formar um loop fechado,
e estamos esperando algo melhor que um código de distância 4. No entanto, alguns loops fechados de
erros X adjacentes estão eles mesmos no estabilizador — lembre-se de que temos um gerador X estabilizador para cada vértice na
rede, e se multiplicarmos geradores X estabilizadores adjacentes podemos formar loops fechados de operações X
como temos bem aqui para o loop fechado que construímos há alguns momentos. Então alguns loops fechados de erros X,
como o mostrado aqui, na verdade não são erros de forma alguma, porque estão no estabilizador — então não fazem absolutamente nada ao espaço de código. Há, no entanto,
alguns loops fechados de erros X que não estão no estabilizador e, portanto, representam erros não-triviais que passam
despercebidos pelo código. E há uma forma bastante simples de caracterizar os diferentes tipos de
loops. Loops que cruzam cada linha na rede — ou seja, cada linha vertical de cima a baixo e cada linha horizontal
da esquerda para a direita — um número par de vezes são sempre produtos de geradores X estabilizadores. Isso inclui o exemplo
mostrado na tela, assim como loops que podem ser muito mais complicados, incluindo a possibilidade de cruzarem as fronteiras periódicas, mas
mesmo assim, multiplicando esses loops fechados de erros X por geradores X estabilizadores, eles podem ser efetivamente reduzidos a
nada. E certamente é verdade, aliás, que só podemos obter loops como esses multiplicando geradores X estabilizadores, porque cada gerador X estabilizador
coloca um número par de operações X em cada linha horizontal e em cada linha vertical.
O outro tipo de loop fechado que podemos ter é aquele que cruza pelo menos uma linha um número ímpar de vezes, como
o mostrado aqui, que cruza cada linha horizontal apenas uma vez. E aqui está outro exemplo que cruza
cada linha vertical apenas uma vez. Então esses são exemplos de erros não-triviais que passam despercebidos pelo código, mas o ponto
fundamental aqui é que a única forma de formar um loop fechado como este é dando a volta no Toro — seja ao redor do buraco no
meio do Toro ou através do buraco, ou poderia ser os dois. Esta é uma propriedade topológica
relacionada ao Toro — é tudo sobre os buracos, basicamente, e é por isso que isso é chamado de código corretor de erros quântico
topológico. Em termos dessa visualização de uma rede bidimensional com fronteiras periódicas, uma cadeia nessa categoria deve
dar a volta em uma ou ambas as fronteiras periódicas de uma forma que torna impossível contrair esse loop a um
ponto multiplicando-o por geradores X estabilizadores. Tal cadeia pode ser mais
complicada do que a ilustrada aqui, mas este é o mais curto que tal loop pode possivelmente ser, porque ele precisa de alguma forma dar a volta
em uma ou ambas as fronteiras periódicas, e o que isso implica é que o peso mínimo de um erro
não-trivial indetectável é L. Qualquer loop fechado com menos erros do que isso deve se enquadrar na primeira categoria e, portanto,
estar no estabilizador. E cadeias de erros que não formam loops fechados são detectadas pelo código. É isso — é por isso que este código
funciona. E o que obtemos é um código estabilizador [[2L², 2, L]] — estamos usando 2L²
qubit para codificar 2 qubit e o código tem distância L. A seguir, vou dizer um pouquinho sobre
a correção de erros com o código Tórico, embora não vá a fundo nos detalhes. Se medirmos a síndrome e
virmos algo diferente da síndrome toda-mais-1 — onde estou falando aqui apenas dos geradores Z estabilizadores —
então os resultados menos um nos indicam as extremidades de uma ou mais cadeias de erros X adjacentes, e podemos tentar corrigir
esses erros emparelhando os resultados menos um e formando uma cadeia de correções X entre eles, e ao
fazer isso faz sentido escolher caminhos mais curtos para nossas correções. Por exemplo, se medirmos uma
síndrome como a mostrada aqui, então poderíamos escolher este caminho entre os tiles infelizes e aplicar gates X
como correções ao longo deste caminho. Claro que a cadeia de erros real causando a síndrome poderia ter
sido diferente, como a mostrada aqui, mas tudo bem — desde que os erros e as correções juntos
se enquadrem no estabilizador. Também pode ser que nossas correções completem um loop ao redor do
Toro, o que é ruim porque ao fazer isso causamos um erro lógico. Então esta estratégia de corrigir
ao longo de caminhos mais curtos corrige erros de baixo peso, mas pode não funcionar para erros de peso maior — mas é claro que não podemos
esperar nada mais de qualquer código corretor de erros quântico. Mais provável talvez — dependendo do modelo de ruído — é que
observemos um monte de menos uns na síndrome, e neste caso podemos usar algoritmos clássicos eficientes para nos ajudar
a emparelhá-los e encontrar um erro de peso mínimo representando a síndrome. Como mencionei na lição anterior,
isso pode nem sempre corrigir a explicação mais provável para a síndrome, mas funciona muito bem em geral
e sempre consegue corrigir erros com peso estritamente menor que metade da distância L. E também devo
mencionar que há outras estratégias mais adequadas para diferentes modelos de erros. Já se passaram mais de 25 anos desde que o
código Tórico foi descoberto, e nesse tempo houve bastante trabalho em códigos corretores de erros quânticos, incluindo
outros códigos corretores de erros quânticos topológicos inspirados pelo código Tórico, bem como códigos baseados em diferentes
ideias. Certamente não posso te dar uma lista abrangente de todas as diferentes construções de código que são conhecidas, mas vou arranhar a superfície
só um pouco e mencionar brevemente alguns exemplos bem conhecidos. Primeiro, acontece que não é
realmente essencial que o código Tórico tenha fronteiras periódicas — ou seja, é possível recortar apenas uma parte do código Tórico e
colocá-la plana em uma superfície bidimensional, em vez de em um Toro, e o que obtemos ao fazer isso é chamado de código de
superfície. Por exemplo, se cortarmos as arestas de uma rede no padrão mostrado aqui com as chamadas arestas rugosas no
topo e na parte inferior e arestas lisas nos lados, e correspondentemente incluirmos casos de borda para os geradores estabilizadores,
então obtemos um código que pode codificar apenas um qubit desta vez, mas o código ainda assim herda as características mais
importantes do código Tórico. Em particular, erros não-triviais indetectáveis para este código devem
corresponder a cadeias de erros que vão da aresta esquerda à aresta direita ou de cima a baixo,
dependendo se são cadeias de erros X ou erros Z, respectivamente. Também é possível cortar
as arestas diagonalmente para obter o que às vezes são chamados de códigos de superfície rotacionados, e fazer isso pode ser útil para tornar
os códigos mais econômicos em termos de quantos qubit são usados. Por exemplo, se pegarmos este código de superfície
e descartarmos alguns dos qubit, deixando um quadrado orientado diagonalmente, obtemos outro código de
superfície, desde que especifiquemos os geradores estabilizadores na fronteira da forma correta. Diagramas como este são
úteis para deixar claro como os geradores estabilizadores são definidos, onde tiles pretos incluindo os arredondados nas bordas indicam geradores X estabilizadores
e os brancos indicam geradores Z estabilizadores. Os da fronteira, aliás, são apenas geradores estabilizadores XX
ou ZZ de 2 qubit desta vez, e você vai ver comumente esses diagramas rotacionados em
45°. Outra classe interessante de códigos, que também se enquadra na categoria geral de códigos topológicos, são os códigos de
cor. Não vou explicar exatamente como eles funcionam, mas uma forma de pensar sobre eles é que são generalizações geométricas
do código Steane de 7 qubit. Então vamos considerar o código Steane de sete qubit e supor que numeramos nossos
qubit usando a convenção de ordenação KCET como mostrado aqui na tela. Podemos então associar esses sete
qubit com os vértices do grafo mostrado aqui, e o que descobrimos é que os geradores estabilizadores correspondem
aos tiles ou faces formadas pelas arestas do grafo, e para cada tile sempre temos um gerador Z estabilizador
e um gerador X estabilizador que atuam de forma não-trivial precisamente nesses qubit que se encontram nos vértices daquele
tile. Isso é legal porque, assim como no código Tórico, temos localidade geométrica para este código, então não precisamos
mover qubit por longas distâncias para medir geradores estabilizadores, e o fato de que os geradores Z e X estabilizadores sempre atuam de forma não-trivial em
exatamente os mesmos conjuntos de qubit também é interessante por razões conectadas com a computação quântica tolerante a falhas, sobre a qual
falarei mais na próxima lição. Códigos de cor são códigos corretores de erros quânticos que generalizam este
padrão básico, onde fazemos essencialmente a mesma coisa, exceto com grafos diferentes. Por exemplo, aqui está um grafo com
19 vértices que funciona. Isso nos dá um código que codifica 1 qubit em 19 e que tem
distância cinco. São chamados de códigos de cor, aliás, porque uma das condições exigidas sobre o grafo é que as faces possam ser coloridas com três cores, o que significa
que podemos colorir as faces com três cores e nunca temos duas faces da mesma cor compartilhando uma aresta. As
cores na verdade não importam para o código em si — simplesmente temos geradores estabilizadores X e Z para cada face independentemente de sua cor, mas as cores
acabam sendo importantes para analisar como ele funciona. Então essas são duas famílias de códigos bastante conhecidas,
mas há muitas outras construções conhecidas, incluindo as baseadas em ideias similares a essas famílias de código, bem
como outras completamente diferentes. Um exemplo específico de um código corretor de erros quântico que foi recentemente
descoberto por alguns dos meus colegas na IBM é conhecido como o código gross, cujo nome vem do fato de que gross é uma dúzia de
dúzias, ou 144. Em particular, este código codifica 12 qubit em 144 qubit e tem
distância 12. Não vou explicar como este código funciona em detalhes — é similar ao código Tórico, exceto que cada um dos
geradores estabilizadores agora envolve dois qubit adicionais que estão um pouco mais distantes. Ele não tem um embedding planar
como um código de superfície, mas tem o chamado biplanar embedding, o que significa que duas camadas de qubit são necessárias em vez
de uma. Ele se enquadra em uma família de códigos chamada códigos de bicicleta bivariate, e o que é particularmente notável sobre eles é
que são muito mais eficientes do que o código Tórico ou um código de superfície, no sentido de que muito mais qubit podem ser codificados enquanto simultaneamente eles
toleram aproximadamente a mesma taxa de erros. Para o código gross, 144 qubit adicionais são necessários para a medição de
síndrome, então o número total de qubit necessários é 288, o que o torna um candidato muito promissor para a tecnologia atual.
E isso conclui esta lição, que foi sobre construções de códigos corretores de erros quânticos, incluindo códigos CSS, o código Tórico e um
vislumbre de outras construções de código quântico, incluindo códigos de superfície e códigos de cor. Espero que você se junte a mim para a
próxima e última lição da série sobre computação quântica tolerante a falhas, que aborda o desafio de realizar
computações em estados quânticos codificados usando operações e componentes de computação que são eles mesmos sujeitos a
erros. Até mais!